bonjour atom alors quelles sont les
revendications de ces jeunes
manifestants beaucoup d'indications pour
ces jeunes évidemment il souhaite une
vraie loi climat c'est ce qu'on peut
voir sur un certain nombre de pancartes
qui sont ici génération sans avenir
c'est également ce qui est écrit sur
cette banderole que vous voyez sur le
devant de ce cortège qui s'est élancé
donc de la place du panthéon il ya
quelques minutes en direction d'une
place non loin de l'assemblée nationale
il réclame donc une vraie loi climat
parce qu'ils estiment que la loi climat
qui a été quittée en train d'être
examiné à l'assemblée nationale ne
répond pas aux enjeux de cette lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique on sait
qu' il ya un certain nombre de mesures
de la convention citoyenne pour le
climat qui n'ont finalement pas été
retenu par les et cultive alors ici on
demande des mesures concrètes
il s'agit surtout de jeunes personnes de
très jeunes militants qui se sont
rassemblés que ce soit des militants
d'organisations syndicales politiques ou
associatives avec plus donc le même
désir d'avoir une loi à la hauteur donc
de ses enjeux pour le climat propose
d'écouter un témoignage que nous avons
pu recueillir tout à l'heure dans cette
manifestation
on veut pas être la génération sacrifiée
la génération sacrifiée à la fois à
cause de la précarité mais aussi à cause
des réformes climat à cause d'eux du
coup franc climatique face auxquels on
est face auquel le gouvernement ne fait
rien l'état français a déjà été condamné
pour une action climatique
aujourd'hui il a essayé de prendre un
peu sa revanche de faire une belle
communication autour d'une convention
climat la réalité c'est qu'il ne prend
plus aucune de leurs propositions
quasiment l'elysée aujourd'hui s'est
transformé en agence de communication
nous on a des revendications on a des
propositions pour le climat il faut
faire la transition énergétique
il faut planifier la bifurcation
écologique on peut pas continuer à
produire aujourd'hui comme on produisait
hier qu'à des réformes apprendre et d
aider réforme forte mais pour ça il faut
un peu de courage politique pour ça ça
coûte de l'argent ça et on le dit aussi
c'est pas possible dans le cadre des
traités européens
donc oui il ya urgence à agir contre le
climat la situation aujourd'hui elle est
pas viable d'ici quelques dizaines
d'années notre terre ne sera peut-être
plus vivable alors il faut agir tout de
suite mais pour agir tout de suite il
faut faire autre chose que se repeindre
en vert tous les trois jours mêlant
candu donc enjeux climatiques m'a pas
seulement beaucoup ici le manifeste
également par rapport à la précarité
étudiants penser la crise sanitaire a
plongé un certain nombre d'étudiants en
situations très précaires et cela à
venir ajouter de l'instabilité pour
certains et puissant qu en manque de
perspectives pour l'avenir c'est la
raison pour laquelle ici les
manifestants parlent donc de génération
sacrifiée et peu ma merci beaucoup pour
tout ces précisions